attention on accueille françois mallet
les quêtes avec new harmony
[Applaudissements]
est ce que nous disons c'est c'est pour
qu'elle enquête après qu'un rapport je
suis pas ça de laquelle raffut rui
mondiale ont en plus un truc qui va
paris ça n'a pas du tout mes mélodies ya
d'abord on dirait une meuf qui équipent
à deauville j'adore ça excuse moi tu
t'es cru chez ta mère
non je me suis cru chez chelal et
laurent boyer mais toi là et il est
blond il cherche l'amour
il se demande d'ailleurs où sont les
femmes patrick juvet et avait pas
[Applaudissements]
et
l'état
alors
et
[Applaudissements]
il est un peu habillée comme comme à dax
c'était samedi ça va il permettra
bitches 13ème et minimes ont bataillé en
maintenant les formats sont les rois du
rock n'roll
c'est une tristesse absolue vous allez
voir c'est parti christine et raymond
[Applaudissements]
là
et
les deux mois accusé mois le csa regarde
allez merci regardez leur dirai de
trajet de dragées je sais pas ce que
vous avez à fond les deux
[Applaudissements]
c'est là ouais c est ce qu on a fait
tout ça pour vous donc la question que
j'ai envie de vous poser est ce que ça
vous fait plaisir
[Rires]
non vraiment on a fait tout ça moi je le
connais les originaux tu comprendrais
que quand je vois ça je rigole ça ils
sont mais vous avez christine
adolescents c'est super bon ah non non
mais franchement honnêtement après un
gros mandat du csa faire d'ailleurs ils
vont tous leur joie que ce avec et
olivier schrameck qui va peut être finir
son mandat le président lui fait ça on
descendait motion il veut faire crouler
nom-là 23 janvier doit aujourd'hui il
nous reste en place et peut-être faire
la compagnie créole je suis parti je
vois là ou là des costumes bah voilà
s'il veut venir voulait lui faire un
petit bisou
alors cher olivier j'ai adoré le mandat
avec vous c'était vraiment beau n'a
d'ailleurs cet après midi j'ai croisé
l'ancien président michel boyon
dans le lot attend avec plaisir surtout
ce pas mon poste voilà bah voilà et si
on veut non il peut ramener les trois
bars certain plaisir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
allez on y va on va cueillir maintenant
à alors là il faut bien faire
est-ce qu'on accueille sheila et ringo
ça va être sa sphère dur et ils sont
fougueux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on est dessus
le soutien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais ça va pas bien on laisse les
gondoles à venise et vous allez assez
votre ci pourront vestiaires vont
traîner la patte on vous le dit c'est
vrai là mais franchement et jouent alors
ça c'est pas si boucher vous j'ai senti
chez pas quand il ya eu un comme la
laponie en avant l après la police vous
arrête à l'heure là eu un avant et un
après le comptage
j'ai apprécié il accroche quoi un petit
très classe arriver gros truc à sky bien
sûr le retour du relou c'est important
voilà merci allez on va enchaîner ah oui
ah oui ah merde je sens que ça va le
faire très rapidement c'est catherine
lara a malheureusement c'est gilles
verdez
[Applaudissements]
c'est la longueur
mon
[Applaudissements]
six autres j'avais 22 du bo qui sont je
trouve hyper beau c'est gentil je te
jure à jamais du coeur mais tu as trouvé
tous titouan c4 est certaine je suis pas
une coiffure comme ça je te suis avec
les lunettes et tobago cerrone ambertois
ouais ouais c'est bien mais c'est pas
merci sa belle voix soit il est pas beau
tennis c'est dans ses cordes
[Applaudissements]
regardez
costumes bien qu'on va accueillir
maintenant france gall au délire eux ils
n'auront pas de suite regardé ça
problèmes que vous vous n'êtes pas
france gall non pas physiquement lui
retient celle à jour en mieux si vous
êtes spacer eux
non on a changé parce que aller mieux à
la personne après ouais franchement bien
alors en fait le un peu parce qu'on le
faire aussi avec la personne d'après
alors on pouvait qu on a calé à la
deuxième personne également alors on va
cueillir chez là parce que c'était en
fait c'était celle là c'est sûr fait pas
parce que vous voulez france gall de
suite chez l'as pêcheurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aulas
m
[Applaudissements]
deux minutes c'est moi non mais là c'est
celle elle est hôtesse de l'air on m'a
dit mettez vous là bas fait le tout les
cénacois pas du tout
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la tenue est pas en fait il ya urgence
on rit je vous le dis on a fait ce qu'on
appelle une miss france ait eu un couac
parce qu'on tienne
quoique on se voit se rattraper voilà
mais bravo en tout cas parce que je
croyais avoir delphine arrivé j'ai dû
kenny dans ma tête mais qu'est ce qui se
passe cette émission est normalement
carré et voilà et tous parents non ça va
pas ça on a oublié quelqu'un à merde ah
oui ah oui je crois qu'on va l'oublier
oui ah bah non il nous reste qui
manquent matthieu delormeau
est ce que voulait vraiment aller au
parti
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi pourquoi on peut faire
n'importe quoi de mal à faire enrico
macias et lambersart
moi je vais toujours ça beaucoup plus
gai que l'original calédonie moi cette
can
[Applaudissements]